economic growth at north east derbyshire
county council
responsible for the growth strategy and
part of that we've recently launched a
skill strategy and we are acutely aware
of the need to bridge the skills gap in
our area
in fact you know i think skills gap is a
a problem across the united kingdom
um skills not just to increase um life
chances improvement in potential but for
our residents also it's about actually
improving productivity
one of the key factors in the declining
productivity is skills and sadly too
many of our local employees complain
that they can't get the right employees
the right skills
and this is not just about the finished
project we all know that
we learn lots on the job
with the right kind of support
but it's also often about getting the
right attitude and aptitude and the
softer skills and that's what employees
require
so the rise um is an innovative
award-winning and unique business
support initiative that connects small
and medium-sized businesses across the
chevy city and north dakota region
working with talented hardworking
graduates and it's it's about really
trying to aim to provide
small businesses with access to
graduates to talent skills innovation
whilst giving graduates access to
fantastic opportunities great career
progression and the chance to make an
impact on our
wonderful region and i'm delighted today
to be joined by two people and louise
barnwood for rice itself and also a
local business uh businessman rbs
environmental uh alan heiress and
introduce those two now a little bit
more detail
louise is a project manager for the rise
scheme and she joined the project in
2020
priceless louise worked in both public
sector and professional service
companies within their hr operations and
recruitment teams and has managed all
aspects of the recruitment cycle and has
led on national graduate recruitment
campaigns
she is responsible for the overall
delivery and management of the rise
project including sme engagement and
candidate screening and she's here today
to tell a little bit more about the rise
scheme and how it could support you to
recruit a talented graduate into your
business
and i'll just introduce alan as well so
um alan uh very very pleased that you
could come today i think it's really
important to hear from
employees i think recruiting the talent
the cost actually recruiting uh
graduates and employees is enormous and
it is important to get the right fit so
with the support respect from rise and
listen to your experience now allen is
the managing director for
res res environmental limited it's an
urban drainage and environmental
consultancy set up in 2003 and based in
killer marsh here in northeast
derbyshire
the company operates in the water and
construction industry and specializing
in all aspects of wastewater and river
modeling flood risk storm water
management and drainage design and i
have to say that's a business that i
think is
naturally growing
sadly but very important
a key area suspecting a growing um
growing sector of our economy allen has
over 40 years of experience in this
niche sector imagine the growing company
employing 20 staff
and apparently home and abroad
and allen says that he has found it
difficult
to recruit
staff in this niche sector
and therefore the business took decision
to cruise at graduate level providing
its own in-house training support and
experience to promote from within
and such the rise programs have been a
significant part of their growth
strategy and then
hopefully we'll be able to tell us more
from the employers point of view and i'm
really pleased um to um to to introduce
both of our speakers today there will be
a opportunity for questions and answers
after this session
um and we hope really to encourage more
small businesses to
think about the rise scheme in terms of
employing
graduates and
i don't want to be all doom and gloom
about this because i've had the
privilege of working with maria who's
here today as an intern and i've met a
number of school leaders recently and
i've been really impressed by the
quality and caliber of our young
graduates and
i feel very optimistic for the future uh
often job search and job matching is
about supply and demand and finding the
right match so it does a little bit um
louise philip like a
match.com situation so um
so yeah so so hopefully um
all questions be answered i think all
the details how to get a hold of
you louise and the rice project will be
on the end of the presentation yes
that's right yes yeah
over to you at least thank you brilliant
thank you very much that lovely warm
welcome carolyn i'm going to share my my
screen now share my slides
hope you can all see that
um
welcome everybody thank you very much
for joining us today um as caroline
mentioned we're here to talk about rise
um and how ryze can support businesses
to recruit graduates and that's what's
the purpose of this for this session
today
okay so the value of rise um it is a
support initiative designed to help smes
in the chevy city region to recruit
talented graduates it is was originally
formed back in september of 2013
uh and it had various sort of
permutations
during that general time as well
it's part funded by the two shepherd
universities the sheffield halloween
university of sheffield uh and in
september 2019 we secured additional
funding so additional funding from the
european union of an additional 685 000
pounds
this is meant that the offering is
slightly changed in terms of what we can
provide service wise to the businesses
so that includes a one-off grant payment
so a thousand pounds for most roles and
then two and a half thousand pounds for
more high-tech specialist type roles as
well really the aim of the project is to
help to remove the barriers to graduate
proven smes they face
and to equip them with the tools and
know how to become independent confident
graduate employees going forward so it's
not just about getting bums on seats but
about giving businesses the schools and
skills and tools they need to recruit
going forward as well once we're once
we're no longer here
okay so the value of rise um we
commissioned an independent economic
impact evaluation report um which
identified that a net juve was 7.7
million pounds
and the impressive return of investment
of 14 pounds every one pound spent on
the scheme
so it just demonstrated the phenomenal
impact ryan's having on the shelter to
region uh we've supported over 500
businesses to advertise over segment
graduate jobs so it really helps
demonstrate the real impact that ryze is
having on the region's economy
okay so we're going to have a little bit
a little bit later on from alan and so
it was a real life um example of a
business using rise but just want to
share some sort of
some examples of the value of rise and
why we'd encourage business to use to
use us to recruit to graduate
so provide them first of all with
visibility in a highly competitive
market you know we're very conscious
that out there there's a lot of uh
larger companies international national
companies recruiting with big flashy you
know graduate programs and so on so it
can feel at times smes get lost amongst
all that so we give them a voice we give
them a presence in that market by using
things such as our eyes our nationalized
platform such as prospects and our
relationship with the two universities
to help promote their business and their
roles there's a fantastic opportunity
they're out there for the graduates i
think sometimes there is a misconception
that graduates are only going to want to
work for large
scale companies that isn't true there
are plenty of graduates out there that
would much rather work for an smes
but they can have a real impact um
within that business
we give them access to a wide pool of
graduate talent so we do that a few
again our national platforms we can
reach uk and international uh graduates
we already close with our two chevy
universities and they've got real wide
reach for their you know final year
students knows their alumni as well
so reaching out a wide pool of talent
out there
we support business to create a graduate
from the ambulance so we work with the
business to understand you know
who are the business
you know what their plans of the future
where does that graduate role sit within
the business and help to pull together a
graduate friendly adverts making sure
that it's reflected the fact that that
graduate they have limited work
experience and so on i've been thinking
about what would attract a graduate when
they're looking at applying for a role
we undertake the candidate screen i'll
go into a bit more detail about that a
little bit later on but we support the
candidate screening process so the
intention is that when we put your
candidates forward to file into you to
you they're the best and the best we've
screened them we've got rid of the poor
candidates we've put forward to the
strongest candidates that we think will
be a good fit for your business
also touch on the fact that we are
looking to support you to become
independent recruiters going forward we
do provide tools and templates and
guides to help uh visit the other
process
and things such as file interview
guidelines and example questions for
example and also things thinking ahead
so things around graduate retention
development the tools that you can use
going forward to help
develop and also retain your graduate in
that position
all the documents are free to sort of
pick and choose as you want they're not
mandatory they're all in word documents
so it's really for you to pick and
choose and use how you see fit and how
it fits within your business
and then most importantly it's done by a
team that are both personable and very
knowledgeable the people that work on
the rise scheme have experience of
supporting the graduate programs whether
in the university or outside of it and
in some cases our recent graduates
themselves who understand it from that
side of things and things as well
so why are we going to graduate
um so somebody can be hesitant to
recruit a graduate i just want to run
through some examples of why it's a good
idea to consider having a graduate
so first of all
when graduates enter the labour market
they've bring them a fresh set of skills
which they're keen to put into practice
those graduates who are actually seeking
to work with sme are keen to take on
extra responsibility
from an early stage in their career and
a real positive can do mindset so they
want to kind of get involved get hit the
ground running and have an impact within
that business
secondly our graduates like to come with
you as a blank canvas with limited work
experience but that doesn't have to be
seen as a negative
it means that you have not yet picked up
any bad working habits which we all have
i'm sure i can say myself i have
to help you to sort of mold them and
build them and develop into what you
need as a business
they're also very good if you're looking
to go and develop your business with a
limited budget we appreciate it for some
businesses particularly just starting
out budget can be tight
so rather than investing in in a more
experienced higher will be more costly
you know a gradually more cost effective
option
so you can look to again invest in them
develop them hopefully thinking about
them developing in that business and
growing and progressing to a to another
home
and it also means that they're much more
likely to be loyal to the business if
you've invested time and money into into
their development
and finally graduates can be an ideal
solution for filling skills gaps
graduates often don't follow a linear
career i'm prior example i did film a
literature university i'm now working in
kind of improvement so quite a bit of a
shift there so what you find is that
they like to choose questions that not
directly related to a degree
and coming from a different background
or discipline can help them bring a
fresh perspective and tons of new ideas
to your business because they've got a
fresh pair of eyes they could bring new
ideas you know experience they've gained
from university or maybe part-time work
can all be applicable applied applied to
your business as well
so here's the team here's my lovely rise
team so i've got myself as the rise
project manager i'm joined by my
colleague amber who is the sme
engagement manager and so amber's role
is really that early stage of the smes
so working with them
to and support them with drafting their
adverts and so on to that initial period
we then my colleague annie
and annie's the candidate engagement
manager so annie's role is really around
candidate support so she's involved very
heavily in the candidate screening
process
offering guidance for candidates when
they are applying for roles and so on
she leads that section
and then my two colleagues sarah and
anne who are a job share who are the sme
relationship managers and their roles
are really keen
and what they're doing is ongoing
support so the rise scheme is about yes
getting a graduate into role
but also longer term for that is about
how we can support businesses making
relevant connections in within the
shepherd city regions things like the
growth hub for example but also within
the two universities that's where anna
and sarah's role comes in
so they play a key part of that process
making connections checking in with the
businesses at three months and six
months once the graduates start to see
how things are going and they then make
those relevant connection links into the
universities for example whether that be
things around internships placements
projects they helped us sort of develop
that relationship between the businesses
and the two universities as well
so eligibility so for business to use
rise we do have some eligibility
criteria so they do have to be an sme so
that is looking for they have to be less
than 250 employees
they must be based in the chef city
region which does include northeast
derbyshire
and they have to be looking to recruit
new additional graduate level jobs
and they also mean to be new to graduate
recruitment or looking to recruit
graduates in a new way so maybe have
fairly limited experience in how to
recruit graduate may have done it
several years ago but not it's not a
regular occurrence for example and
that's where we can really add value and
support with the process
um so as part of the commitment from the
business themselves we ask that they
employ the graduate for a minimum of 12
months and that is a shift so
an old rise if you like prior to
additional funding it could be a
short-term internship
we are looking for ideally a fixed term
traumas or actually ideally permanent
role for that graduate again it's
looking at long-term
uh plan rather than just a short-term
fix if you like
we'd ask that they pay a market salary
and when we do have discussions with
business at the early stages doing the
advert we do talk about sort of salary
expectations from the graduate you know
examples of selling ranges for similar
roles and so on
we do kind of guide and talk you through
that process unless they do have a line
manager did you have a support someone
who support them and and guide when they
do start with your business and good
quality work you know we want them to to
feel valued and further adding value to
the business and make sure they've got
good quality work as part of that
and then finally we do add that as the
business commit to our time scales so
each we have a cohort that lasts around
three or four months
with key dates that we do share with
businesses and we do ask that they do
work to those time scales
and that they don't advertise the
vacancy elsewhere and we ask for that
because it is a public funded project
a lot of time and money and investment
browser will go into that that process
we dress that they don't advertise
anywhere else um while we're supporting
them through the process as well
so i'm going to talk to you now with the
sort of sme customer journey to talk
through the different stage of the
process
and what support the business has
received from ourselves
okay so first of all if your business is
considering working with rise we will
undertake an initial eligibility call
tens of last between so 10-15 minutes
and a quick chat with the business where
we'll kind of explain the rise process
in a bit more detail with them
and also check the business eligibility
to make sure you know they are our sme
they're in the right region and so on
we'll have a brief chance part of that
as well about the role itself just to
get a feel and make sure it just sounds
like a graduate level role
as long as both parties are happy we'd
look to arrange then a second more
structured call which would last about
an hour and that's a more of a deep dive
if you like so at that point we talk a
bit more about who the business are you
know where does the role sit within the
business what kind of um skills they're
looking for for individual what are the
criteria of that for that role and so
i'll work with them to build up a advert
um we'd build an advert with them um and
as part of that would also talk about
things such as salary range you know
degree subject
and making sure they're thinking careful
what the actual criteria are for that
position making sure they are they're
clear on what they're after really
important for a graduate looking at a
job spec they understand what what they
need to have to be able to apply for
that role
and so then we'll draft that advert we
share it with the business and we'll
maybe a bit of ongoing discussion until
we finalize that process
so
sme engagements record which is this
initial stage lasts just over five weeks
so we'll work with businesses during
that period have those initial calls and
there was a longer hour-long sessions to
sort of flesh out that the um advert and
so on
we then go through to the advertising
stage all rise roles will go live on the
same day so big kind of launch of rise
and promote that for the universities
and our social media and so on and all
our roles will go live on prospects so
prospects is a graduate job board it's
got a wide reaching well-established um
platform
and they work really close with us to
help advertise our roles to promote them
to relevant graduates and all that sort
of they've got a really good
relationship with them
so we'll advertise the roles they're are
advertised for a three week period
and we'll keep business up to date with
how they're after
how their venues are going during that
stage because all applications will come
through to us and we will screen them as
and when they come in
so we'll screen those applications they
come in
and they do a short application question
with their application form we will
screen that and if suitable they'll go
to the next stage of the process
so the next stage for most roles will be
a video interview so they will go online
it's a they record it recorded answering
four simple questions which again we
will screen
as part of that process and at that
point if they're suitable they go to the
final stage which will generally be any
assessment center
um assessment centres are done online we
moved to online last year as you can
imagine with covered and so on moved to
an online um
process and that's worked really well
for graduates they've found that's been
a positive and positive change for them
we do it online where they do a group
exercise and they written exercise
it's quite a nice day as well because
they may be they may apply for all
different roles
it doesn't feel like a competitive
environment they work much more
collaboratively together because they
could be going through completely
different positions and completely
different businesses so it's actually
quite a nice assessment center to run i
quite enjoy doing them actually
there's an alternative route so for most
sort of general routes uh general um
recruitment it will go through those
stages so application
video interview and assessment center
for more technical roles so that could
be things like engineering roles for
example we offer an alternative route
which isn't up to the business whether
you want to use it or not but we do
offer an alternative route our technical
room if you like where they do an
application form with application
question as they as the others do
and then the next stage would be a
technical test
so that technical test can be provided
by us so we have a couple of standard
ones that we can provide or
alternatively um they can provide a
technical test for us trade minister
once that's been screened again if
they're suitable they then go forward to
the business for the final interview
stage
the reason we offer that alternative
route for technical
roles so twofold
first of all um
we know that those type of graduates are
tend to be more in demand
you know the short supply of those
graduates and there's lots of people you
know trying to get their attention
getting to apply for all and so on so i
want to try and keep the process simple
and short as we can for the for the
graduate
but also we tend to find it again
generally speaking is those graduates
who are more technical um don't perform
as well
in things like the video interview and
assessment center
so we tend to offer that's an
alternative route try again source the
best candidates for the business we like
to be adaptable in that respect
we also have our employer briefing which
businesses attend uh it's a two-hour
session again done online and that talks
through you know with bryce post and
we've done so far also support around
the family interview process things to
think about in terms of how to
manage that process and questions and so
on but also again thinking about um
graduates going forward once you've got
that graduating position you know how
can you look to think about how you can
maintain them so what's a graduate
looking for in a role what can you do to
try and retain the manchester
development so again thinking that
long-term long-term picture
so once we've done our screen ourselves
that lasts around five weeks in total so
that's that application video interview
assessment center we'll then do a wrap
up internally and determine which
candidates should go forward to the
business of final interview so that's
tends to be anyway between four and six
candidates and it will vary between you
know through different roles some roles
will maybe have lower candidates if it's
harder to fill roll uh some may have
slightly higher so it's around four to
six candidates
we'll put those forward to the business
they'll get kind of a candidate pack
which will have any documentation
candidates provided so that's can be cv
covering better
some provide additional documentation
like certificates and so on and also
their scores so business can see how
they scored through each stage of the
process
we can also support with arranging file
interviews for the business so they want
us to coordinate that process we can do
uh for them they will still undertake
the interviews themselves so we will
support kind of booking candidates in
and the business wants to take the found
interviews themselves
and as i mentioned earlier on we do
provide tools and guides so we do
provide a file interview question
suggestions they can use and things like
that to kind of guide them um for that
process as well
hopefully the business interview and
they find a fantastic candidate which
we're hoping for and they make an offer
to that candidate and hopefully appoint
us they manage that process because
ultimately the candidate will be an
employee of that business and treated
just as any other employee within the
business so that business the business
handle that stage of the process as well
and then as we touched on before um
there is ongoing support and brokerage
um which is which is handled by ann and
sarah as the relationship managers so
once appointed the graduate will
undertake an online graduate development
day it's now a half half day session
and again we'll talk through so that
helping support with that transition
from university life to work life we'll
talk about ways that they can again
develop themselves
and we talk about various different
things talk about things like difficult
conversations and various bits and bobs
to help support them and build their
confidence a little bit when going into
the workplace because it can be quite
daunting particularly strange times
where some graduates may not meet
face-to-face with their employer
straight away and so on just giving them
some some confidence and some talk hints
and tips on how to manage that
transition as well
it's also opportunity for them to
network they meet other graduates in
similar positions conscious that again
they won't have an opportunity to meet
these graduates face-to-face and
assessment center so we help some
you know peer networking if you like as
part of the part of the session
and then we have a three month and six
month reviews with the business so um
someone from my team and then announcer
will have a three-month view with the
business check in how the business doing
how's the graduate settled in and then
talk about any ongoing support or
brokerage they might require
for example into the universities
at that point and or sarah will also
have catch up with the graduate of three
months again checking how they're doing
any support and so on they might need
there's a final checkup of six months as
well with the business and again to
check in how are things going any fed
support and that relationship can be
ongoing if you want to so it's a bit of
a it's up to the business how they want
to manage that going forward but there's
a key three and six months reviews and
then going forward it's up to the
business how they want how much content
they want to have with anal serra going
forward
um it's important to say well there is a
grant payment made to the business so
once the grant once the graduate has
been with the biz for three months
um for the first hire they received that
grant paint we spoke about so again a
thousand pounds or two and a half
thousand pounds so you know it's it's a
nice little boost in terms of thinking
about cost you know onboarding cost of
the graduate you know where it's
thinking about you know
it equipment all that sort of thing that
can perhaps help with covering some of
those additional costs that the business
thinks incurred by harry that are in
that graduate
um we have also introduced from rise six
which is our last cohort um what we're
calling next steps um which is an
extension of our existing support
package
and it's designed for those smes who
have accessed the rise scheme twice or
more before
um business receive the same upfront
support so they still receive the
support with regards to uh drafting
their advert and so on and we still
advertise to the universities and
through uh prospects but then from that
point onwards um the shift in terms of
the screening move to the business
themselves with support from their sme
relationship manager to anal sera will
support them so what happens
applications go directly to the business
and then they're responsible for
screening and shortness in candidates
themselves
and again and they're on hand
you know
helpful in some tips on how to do that
process and the support they may need as
part of that as well
so it's a sort of a shift in given more
responsibility to the business um and
again we had our sort of first cohort
last last time round and we're kind of
looking reviewing that see what works
seeing what different and making
adjustments going forward um we're
hoping that business will find that as a
positive sort of giving them a bit more
control and autonomy over the process
than perhaps they've had that before
so as i mentioned uh our seventh cohort
is currently live it went live today
this morning and so visitors are
interested in finding out more you can
contact my colleague amber the sme
engagement manager and her details are
up there and so our seventh cohort is
live now with graduates due to starts of
december time so december maybe january
january if that works for the business
that's absolutely fine
um if it isn't quite the right time
that's absolutely fine as well we do
have two further cohorts uh coming up
so one that will run january into eight
months the graduate starting april may
time
and then the last one will be running
may till august and so you do have two
other options there if this time wise it
doesn't quite work quite work for you as
well
um it's also worth noting at the end of
each cohort we do kind of what we call a
mini talk form so that is for any
graduates who weren't successful in the
main cohort who are still looking for
roles we can again support businesses
and
with recruiting by attention reaching
out to those candidates who weren't
successful and see if they're interested
in an alternative role as well
okay brilliant um does anyone have any
questions
i am wondering if at this stage it's
worth
pushing the q a session at the very end
but
um i i really want to thank you louise
for this very informative and engaging
presentation it's absolutely fantastic
it's lovely i'm really happy that we get
to spread awareness of all of this of
this scheme and how timely is it that
your cohort starts today so essentially
as soon as this is out businesses can
start signing up for it uh straight away
that's amazing and on that note uh we
also have with us alan from uh res
environmental uh who i've recruited as i
am aware of five graduates to arise
that's quite a few over the past few
years and they've gone through the
entire process and they have some
fantastic insights you know from the
business perspective so alan i'd like to
hand over to you for a little bit of
insight
okay maria thank you very much and thank
you for inviting me along this afternoon
um as was mentioned earlier we um and
we're a small local um sme based in
northeast derbyshire
we work in the field of urban drainage
and we specialize in all aspects of
waste water and river modelling to
assess flood risk
and associated environmental
impacts
we fundamentally build hydraulic models
and these models
assess where it floods
why it floods and then we try and
deliver solutions to mitigate those
flooding problems
as you can imagine
you know
flooding in this country is is um hot
news these days as regular news reports
um you know we talk about global warming
and climate change and changing weather
patterns
and and and and therefore the potential
for our service offering um has got legs
it's got the opportunity to to grow even
further
and we use digital technologies to
construct our models um
you know that that represent really
intense rainfall we we can analyze the
impacts on towns and cities but we can
also analyze the impacts on small local
developments
now um our client base is largely water
companies and the environment agency um
but this is a niche marketplace
um and there's not many of us around
particularly small smes like this that
offer this this service there are larger
corporates out there
um who offer what we do but only as a
small part of many other services
now
in terms of recruitment we have always
been up against um these larger um
conglomerates and we have to be quite
persuasive
in demonstrating why graduates should
come and want to work for a local sme
rather than perhaps
the more glamorous outlook that these
larger conglomerates can can offer or
claim to offer
um
i feel um
as an sme
a local sme we can offer
a different opportunity to graduates
in my opinion
if you get employed by in my industry if
you get employed in
in one of the larger
corporates the graduate can often be
pigeonholed and by that um in
in my world he he or she
will
be asked to focus on only one aspect of
the model build and indeed may only be
allowed to work for
one client um
on a framework over a number of years
um i like to think that um
we try and ensure and that our graduates
get involved in every aspect of the
project cycle right from initial
feasibility
right through the various um aspects of
model build and verification reporting
through to project sign off and and and
and i like to think well i i'm sure that
that sort of level x of experience and
exposure at the start of their career is
something quite special and to be honest
working with rise has helped us to sort
of understand
helps us to understand and articulate
that offer to to people who apply for a
role with us
so so
getting the message across there that
you know the the rise program has has
really helped us um um a great deal in
that regard
and we
um
as you can imagine i don't suppose
you've come across waste water hydraulic
modelers um on a regular basis so um it
is a niche market and and as such we
struggle to find people
with experience
um you know people who can hit the
ground running you know largely because
they they are already tied up in these
larger organizations
and um it's difficult to extract them
from them
so our our recruitment policy
now because of that difficulty
is to recruit at graduate level we train
and develop our staff internally and and
and hopefully promote from within and
and indeed we've got a few examples in
the office here of people not
necessarily through the ground that rise
program as that's only been running with
us for um um three or four years but
we've taken on graduates before we we've
developed them in in our ways in our
standards and we've and they've now been
promoted from from raw graduates through
to sort of the senior model of senior
management type roles within the
business
um
we the directors myself included and
we're not administrators we're engineers
we come from engineering backgrounds you
know um
and and
and so when we do um interviews with
we're so much more comfortable drilling
in to an experienced person
you know we can drill into their
technical know-how we can talk about
project experiences we can challenge
them on technical aspects of of of what
we do
and and we always find it and and have
found it um
and difficult to
to interview graduates
um
as you can imagine prior to rise coming
along you know you can get your
graduates to come along to the interview
they're loud enthusiastic they show a
lot of willingness and keenness um
but equally you can get the quiet the
shy ones the introverted ones who who
you know just general shyness doesn't
you know they've they've got the
knowledge you know but it's it's it it
was so difficult in the past
um
you know to employ and pick up on the
right type of graduate and the the other
the other issue as well with with with
um
working in such a niche market the only
way we could find to get hold of
people with a genuine interest in our
industry was to go through specialized
recruitment agencies
and
i am not a fan of
most of these specialized recruitment
agencies they cost you an arm and a leg
i don't think they do the filtering
that's required
and at the end of the day
um their their fees are are
high to say the least i mean they will
charge anything between 15 and 20 of the
first year's salary which um if you've
got it wrong is um is a cost can be a
costly mistake
um
so
you know while qualifications from our
point of view are important of course
they're important um you know along with
some knowledge and and
interest in our field and by far the
most important aspect um at this stage
for us of the personal traits
um you know
and their ability to blend into our
current team structures
that's that's critical for us
um we've been involved now in the rise
programme as we've said earlier i think
it's through four cohorts and we we've
employed
five graduates
um jane shannon john
all five have now progressed through
um our internal training programme
uh and and now they're valuable members
of the the project team and they're
they're engaged
a variety of environmental projects for
us
um we've found the the service um
um to be of great benefit it's you know
it's saved us time and money it really
has um the rise team um have been very
proactive and they they they really have
provided the support and guidance as
necessary along the way
um
as was mentioned earlier what we found
most useful was the help with the advert
um
i found
apologies i i i can't recall the lady
who came in to draft the advert with us
but she had a flare to to make the job
very attractive and very appealing i
nearly applied for it myself to be
honest after after i saw the advert
um
candidates um um as louise mentioned um
have been filtered during the the rise
pre-interview assessments
um
you know
the video interviews and the work that
they do at the assessment centers looked
into
their their drive their business focus
their professionalism you know um
which as i say are the attributes i'm
i'm most most interested in
um
rise has helped us to pinpoint the wider
traits and knowledge base we are seeking
and and they've supported us to explore
those qualities and candidates during
the interviews
um yeah as stated above
traditional recruit methods we employed
were a bit of a lottery but but to be
honest the rye support has reduced that
risk
as a result the caliber of candidate
during the first three cohorts was
excellent um and the final choice was
really very very difficult um
um i remember the first cohort in
particular we had eight for interview
and there was one which i must admit
didn't take all all of the boxes i was
looking for but the other seven i only
needed one and
it was really a very difficult choice in
the end
um
but
to that regard and it was mentioned
earlier
as we are engineers and not
administrators um
we
found the guidance for the interviews um
really really useful
we
have really taken on
the
rise um template that they provided
we've modified it slightly but
fundamentally the questions are all
based around
um their motivation
um
for the role their interest in the role
um it's based around their work
experience and it doesn't have to be in
our field anyhow i i i'm just keen to
understand what type of work experience
in any field whether it's pushing
supermarket trolleys or something
anything you know work experience um
that um
you know
having been there and done something
like that is important and again i do
tap in a little bit on the technical
knowledge in our field just the basics
just the basic stuff nothing too taxing
but um
it's been really good we obviously we
asked all the candidates
the same sort of questions we mark all
of the candidates in the same way
everything's scored relatively and and
and i i i like to think the decision we
eventually have come up with has been
fair
so really rise has been a really
successful experience for us
um
we're very pleased with the the rise
team they appear very professional they
offer excellent support during and after
and in all honesty they they have
assisted in in raising our profile um
you know
as you can imagine this industry is
going through a boom time at the moment
and we have been growing over growing
over the last two or three years and and
to be honest that the new recruits in
the business have have contributed to
that um brand awareness if you like
that's the that's gone up for us
and um and long may continue so if
anyone out there
are looking for a new graduate and want
to try and tackle that recruitment in a
slightly different way than i would
highly recommend
following the rise programme
thank you very much
any questions thank you very much alan
that's absolutely amazing it is it is
just great to hear how helpful rice has
been for you
and uh as you say recruiting graduates
in your niche market has been a bit of
trouble for you and how they've managed
to help you with all of that throughout
the entire process of recruitment and
helping you to become more independent
in that regard as well so thank you both
andy and louise and
now i'll invite everybody to um ask any
of your questions whether through
microphone or in the chat
and i see jill has already gone ahead
and started putting some questions so
for louise
um how many graduates do you
attract in each
cohort what types of degrees do they
have and what is the retention rate of
the graduates during and after the first
12 months well
um in terms of retention rates at the
moment we have um
uh we've recruited five and to be honest
we've lost one um in all honesty the one
we lost
um the role
wasn't for them so um
that that's absolutely fine that's
absolutely fine
um in terms of um
there's no there's no fixed number in
terms of how many we take on each year
it depends on market conditions of
course
um but at the moment we are a team of 20
and we are looking to go to 25 to 30
over the next 18 months
and in terms of qualifications that was
the other aspect was on the
qualifications
our graduates are qualified in things
like environmental sciences civil
engineering geography because we use
hydraulic modeling software and a lot of
gis mapping systems so the the
geographical know-how and and background
is useful to us
yes
does that answer it
louise do you have anything to add
and just look up as a wider rise point
of view um it depends how many make how
many bakes we're recruiting to but
application numbers overall will range
up between 500 and 700 applications
across all the roles
and so candidates can apply for up to
three roles so we limit how many they
can apply for because obviously if they
apply for too many it gets quite
confusing and really strong candidates
may be put forward for lots of different
roles and that's that's not ideal so
between 500 or 700 per cohort
uh in terms of degree
a wide range of degrees because with
some businesses
on the type of role they're looking to
recruit it can be very open so a
marketing degree for example isn't
always required for a marketing exec
role so it can be quite broad so we have
engineering degrees
marketing journalism english literature
and sports science a vast
range of uh degrees subjects that
applicants will apply with and again for
some roles we need specific ones to know
what they're more but the wider um
degree sector if you like and others can
be anything so the range in terms of the
degrees we get is quite vast really um
and then the last one was the last
question maria um it's about what is the
retention rates that you know of of the
graduates doing and after the first 12
months
so in terms of problems as i said we are
so last of touch point with the business
six months so we don't have exact things
in terms of retention what we do find is
a lot of good news stories we've got
examples of graduates who've progressed
since they've joined businesses we've
got we keep in touch with them through
social media and so on so we'll keep an
eye on their progression we'll see
graduates who have progressed into more
senior positions following their recruit
we haven't got unfortunately specific
details of how many have retained after
that 12 months period unfortunately um
but the batman will still be there for
three months and six months point one
checking
yeah luckily alan got that uh question
for us as well he gave us a little
insight um carolyn what any questions
you'd like to ask yeah i was just
thinking about the filtering i thought
that was a an important point in terms
of
um
going through the traditional
recruitment um the cost of what cost is
now but it must be enormous to recruit
and it must be so
heartbreaking to actually pull that
money and efforts to not get a fit so i
was interested about the filtering and
do um
is is there any opportunities to
continue working with the students and
the universities if you know if you
found it if it's a niche market is there
any aftercare in terms of support the
university is ongoing
so in terms of the so the university
where close is once we start to actually
advertisers and get candidates applying
for roles we will share their details
with the relevant universities
if they're a sheffield hallam or
university chef or graduate their
details will be shared with the
universities to offer support to them so
there is offer we always do directly to
their career services for support during
the process so they move press the next
stage we'll guide them towards their
career service only for the support they
might want in preparation
and the university is fully aware of
what our process is in terms of what
we're assessing at each stage so they
can offer a bit off for the graduate
support so whether it's the application
what they should include on that how to
video into your assessment center and so
on and they're on how to kind of guide
them as and when needed if they want
that additional support to hopefully get
them to the next stage and so on
[Music]
i suspect the grant's probably very
useful for a graduate coming out of
university
just you know just think about you know
the first months of
you know paying for salary rent you know
um
costs of getting to work and
basic stuff so i think that's quite a
nice i would say that as a you know i
think i was a graduate i'd see that's
quite a nice little boost so the
grandparent is paid to the business
themselves
rather than the graduates oh right i
thought it's the graduates it was
it was useful it was views as was
mentioned earlier it
you know particularly in our business
it's a a big part of it so um
to to assist with the it set up um um
the the the grant was very useful yeah
for them for the recording marie i just
asked that question again it sounded
very useful for the grant to go to the
business how useful it was it for you
alan
it was very useful for me carolyn
um
as you can imagine our businesses is it
intensive so um
um the the grant numbers were
went towards new laptops new new
software um to support the graduate in
their early years
yeah yeah it was very good
i'll go ahead jane i was you're gonna
intervene you go ahead okay
i was just wondering because obviously
within northeast derbyshire the majority
of our businesses are
small businesses you know we have about
90 percent of our businesses are
actually small businesses
but like allen so i'm just wondering
what you think are the main
er
challenges for small businesses when
recruiting graduates are they do they
automatically think of
recruiting graduates
i think sometimes yeah there's a there's
two parts i think business will will
sometimes make assumptions that they
will struggle to get graduate so they're
not going to attempt to because they're
going to be lured away by big businesses
which we know isn't true we can evidence
that we've recruited graduates for smes
and if there are graduates out there
that don't want to work for large
organizations and that's part of it and
the other thing i think is the hesitance
when some business in terms of well can
they add value early on you know what
we're going to do with it when they
first start they won't know how this
works or how to do that and all that
sort of thing so that's why we try and
talk to us about things like
transferable skills now they can bring
new ideas fresh perspective to your
business and add value
um from the word get go in terms of what
they can bring outside this perhaps
isn't already internally within your
business and so i think it's just having
a conversation with the business and
talk about the pros and what value the
graduate can add once they do join and
the fact that you know if you get the
right graduate you can make so as we
talked about before kind of mold and
development what you want they're not
experienced how you can already have a
set way of working if you like so you
kind of mold them to some way of working
for your business
yeah thank you
absolutely well uh thank you uh jill has
had to go for a different meeting but
she has put one more question
specifically for for alan i think you've
uh answered one or two of these but i'll
i'll reiterate them so how many
graduates are you taking on a year
and what effect would this have had on
your business if you hadn't been able to
find a graduate
um
right at this moment i suppose we are
looking um
um
two or three years in front of us
and we're looking to recruit perhaps two
graduates per
year as i've said earlier it depends on
market influences
um and what's going out but what's going
on out there in the wider circle
um sorry what was marie what was the
second part of that question second one
is uh what effect would uh with not
finding a way well
obviously we can't grow the teams as we
would like we can't take on the work
that is out there at the moment as
we've said this industry is a boom it's
boom time there's a lot of a lot of work
out there and i'm pleased to say our
reputation is is going up at the moment
and therefore
the opportunity there's bigger and wider
opportunities for us so if we'd not had
the graduates we wouldn't have had the
teams and we wouldn't have been able to
take
take advantage of the opportunities that
are currently out there
certainly so we would have treaded water
rather than just
you know grow
yep sounds like ryze is helping you a
lot there as well so that's uh you know
an advantage for both sounds amazing i
have uh one quick question is to um how
many times can a business use the rice
scheme to actually recruit graduates
because you've said allen and res have
used a couple of times and you've
mentioned uh that you've got an
additional step for businesses who
recruited a couple of times so i'm just
wondering what what what numbers are we
dealing with
so there are no there's no current limit
so you can come back to rise as many
times as you as you want or you need if
you like as long as there is still some
support required as long as you still
got some sort of you know barrier to
recruitment that you need our support we
are still here to help
but as i mentioned it's just a slight
shift in terms of support that you get
if you're coming back you use rise twice
or more before that support will look a
little bit different in terms of our
next step support program uh which is a
bit more was sort of helping the initial
spot
supporting the initial stage as we do in
any recruitment and then sort of taking
a look at a step back and then you lead
on that that second stage of candidate
screening and it still goes to help with
that transition in terms of you taking
the lead on recruitment taking a step
back and giving you the confidence to do
it yourself a bit more
yeah that doesn't make sense and uh i
also it just occurred to me so if you've
provided a certain you know folder of uh
people to recruit to the business are
they um
meant to to recruit one or can they do
they go back if they haven't found the
right person do they go back a step
so there's no obligation so obviously
ideally we want you to find a great
candidate and hire them but it doesn't
always work out you know that's
absolutely fine there's no obligation to
hire a graduate we don't need to hire
somebody who you don't fit things right
for the business and ultimately doesn't
stay on with you that's a waste of your
time and their time and it doesn't make
sense so we'd hope you find somebody but
if there isn't somebody suitable in that
round recruitment that is absolutely
fine that's not as long as you you're
happy that you've got just about the
reason as to why you don't want to
recruit them that's absolutely fine
that's not a problem in any anyway yeah
that's great um
that's uh any that's all from me any any
more questions from anybody
for the meeting oh that's great we've
actually managed to get to this i think
jane do you think this is a good
point to stop the recording